bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 78 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire
ultimate le club zérogène de plaisir à
organiser ce weekend la 12e édition de
zé Pen un tournoi amical qui regroupe
huit équipes franéennes les détails dans
ce magazine aviron le vers y est Thomas
Barou et son coéquipier thbo Collard se
sont imposés en finale du 200 barreurs
poils légers lors des championnats de
France bateauours l' vois est au pte des
Jeux olympiques de Rio nous le recevons
dans quelques instants sur ce
plateau foutsall les finales de la coupe
des iblines se sont déroulé ce dimanche
au complexe sportif Europe à aencour des
rêvés du foot à 11 ce sport compte
aujourd'hui 16 clubs dans le département
retour sur cette compétition et puis
nous parlerons également basket nous
recevrons dans quelques instants
l'équipe senior de trappe l'équipe a
fini à la saison à la 6 6e place du
classement de National
3 ce weekend zéogè le club d'Ultimate de
plaisir organiser la 12e édition de zé
Pen 2 jours de match amicaux avec des
clubs franciliens h équipes se sont
affrontés dans des matchs où le fair
playay et le mettre au mot Milan Po et
William l pour les
images 12e édition déjà pour zerop pour
ce tournoi h équipes composées de 10
joueurs franciliens ont fait le
déplacement l'Ultimate frisbe sport venu
des États-Unis se joue sans arbitre
c'est du gagneterrain on doit arriver à
conquérir le terrain de fin de zone pour
marquer un point ici c'est en 5 cont 5
parce qu'on est en l'intérieur en
extérieur ça sera du 7 contre 7 sur un
terrain de football donc un espace un
petit peu plus libre pour s'exprimer
avec plus de courses et des passes un
peu plus longues pas d'ux ce weekend
pour ce tournoi organisé par zérogène un
moyen pour les clubs de tester ses
joueurs en équipe mixte et de peaufiner
C tactique le côté autoarbitré ça permet
justement de poser le jeu de discuter et
et donc voilà et c'est ça qui est
agréable parce que c'est pas un sport où
on va au contact et justement on se
préserve un petit peu aussi les uns les
autres et du coup ça oblige peut-être
les hommes qui sont peut-être plus
physique à faire attention on apporte un
petit peu notre côté plus posé peut-être
dans le jeu pour plaisir on a une
particularité on joue beaucoup en
défense de zone donc un peu comme tous
les SPORTCO au lieu de défendre un
joueur on défend chacun une zone donc là
on développe ce je en intérieur ce qui
est assez particulier donc c'est notre
spécialité avec 5 à 10 % de licenciés de
plus chaque année zéogè est en constante
croissance une 13e édition de zer P est
déjà programmée pour
2017 après l'Ultimate nous allons
parleriron dans cette émission et du
champon de France versaillais Thomas
Barou on continue donc cette émission
par de l'aviron le versaillais à Thomas
Barou et son coéquipier à THB Collard se
sont posé en finale du 200 barreurs POS
léger lors des championnats de France
bateau courour une compétition qui s'est
déroulée au début du mois à casobon dans
le gerse la paire Barou colar a devancé
la paire Renault solforossi qui était
invaincu depuis 2013 nous reçons du coup
sur ce plateau Thomas Barou bonsoir
Thomas bonsoir alors un peu plus de 15
jours après cette compétition comment
analysez-vous à froid vos performances
euh nos performances ont été à la
hauteur de ce qu'on attendait a pas
travaillé énormément dans cette
embarcation cette année pour se
concentrer déjà un peu plus sur
l'embarcation olympique qui est le
bateau à 4 avec justement la paire
Renault solforisi qu'on qu'on devance
avec lesquel on avait déjà ramé dans le
bateau A4 l'année dernière au
championnat du monde on a fait médaille
de bronze
euh nous on a voilà donc on a réussi à
mettre en progresser par rapport à
l'année dernière à mettre en place ce
qui nous manquait encore l'an dernier à
emmagasiner de l'expérience en course et
à produ produire vraiment une course
très aboutie en finale qui a été la
seule confrontation qu'on a eu cette
année avec l'autre
père et donc on a pas laisser passer
notre notre chance vous étiez favoris ou
vous étiez outsider sur cette c'est
difficile à dire parce que nos
coéquipier étit champion de France ces
trois dernières années donc clairement
il partaient avec un petit avantage mais
ils ont une préparation un peu compliqué
par une petite blessure sur les deux
semaines qui ont précédé le championnat
donc ils ont pas eu de compétition de
préparation donc ils étaient un peu je
pense dans le flou vis-à-vis de leur
performance et nous on était aussi dans
le flou vis-à-vis d'eux parce que
justement comme on les avait pas
rencontré savait pas quels étaient leurs
points fort et leurs faiblesse et on
peut dire vous étiez meilleurs
physiquement euh ça c'est difficile à
dire on était en forme on s'est bien
préparé on na pas fait d'erreur dans la
préparation euh après savoir si ça a été
physique ou technique la différence
entre les deux bateaux c'est difficile
de répondre et comment ça passe cette
relation avec votre coéquipier à thibo
avec thibo ça se passe très bien on est
assez d'accord sur ce qu'on cherche en
bateau sur sur les sensations qu'on
cherche à avoir sur les points
techniques qu'on cherche à travailler en
dehors du bateau on s'entend très bien
aussi il vaut mieux qu'on s'entende bien
parce qu'on est quand même dans des
conditions un petit peu enfin qui qui
relève clairement du sport amateur quand
je vais à Lyon comme on le voit sur les
images pour pour ramer c'est lui qui
m'héberge donc voilà je suis suis chez
lui on est en colocation pas au niveau
des footballeurs non non je peux pas je
peux pas encore me payer l'hôtel chacun
de mes déplacements et si sont nombreux
ouais ce serait pas mal à côté du du
bassin serait pas mal et il y a encore
des des éléments peut-être à améliorer
avecou il y a toujours des éléments à
améliorer même si on commence à être un
bateau assez abouti il nous reste voilà
il nous reste à progresser encore
techniquement chacun de notre côté et à
trouver encore plus de cohésion qu'on en
a déjà même si ça commence à être déjà
bien donc cette victoire devrait vous
permettre d'aller au JO vous confirmez
effectivement on peut on peut y penser
très très sérieusement au championnat de
France donc not nos deux coéquipiers
sont 4 secondes derrière nous et le
bateau qui suit est 10 secondes derrière
donc il commence à y avoir de très gros
écarts pour donner un ordre d'idée 10
secondes ça fait trois longueurs de
bateau donc ça commence à faire une
trentaine de mè c'est non négligeable
donc là clairement en plus comme c'est
le bateau de l'année dernière on a des
gens vécu ensemble de l'expérience
ensemble donc donc ça semble vraiment le
la volonté de l'entraîneur et le
sélectionneur de de continuer dans cette
embarcation là et capitaliser sur
l'année dernière pour encore aller
améliorer notre performance et vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir déjà réussi votre
saison ou vous avez le sentiment que
c'est ce n'est peut-être que le
commencement finalement d'un aventure
que le commencement c'était un point de
passage important et obligé c'est
championnat de France mais on avait déjà
un petit peu la tête tournée vers Rio et
ce depuis le début de l'année parce que
voilà c'est l'objectif majeur de ces qu
dernières années vous vous préparez
clairement pour Rio maintenant
maintenant on se prépare uniquement pour
Rio on a des compétitions intermédiaires
fin mai mi-juin mais voilà l'objectif
unique de la saison c'était Rio et
maintenant on peut s'y dédier
complètement et quelle sera votre charge
de travail sur les prochains mois voulez
dire professionnelle ou sportive
sportive sportive on a encore deux
grosses périodes de de travail là c'est
les les les 2 semaines à venir ensuite
on va enchaîner sur des périodes de une
période de compétition pendant 6 ouais 5
6 semaines où ça va être une alternance
de période de charge mais aussi de
période de récupération pour arriver
assez en forme sur les compétitions pour
pouvoir travailler pendant ces
compétitions et emmagasiner de
l'expérience et puis ensuite on partira
sur la préparation terminale pour les
Jeux Olympiques à la fin du mois de juin
et là jusque pendant les TR qu premières
semaines ça va être du gros gros travail
avec beaucoup beaucoup de volume euh
pour don une idée c'est entre 25 et 30
heur de travail effectif par semaine à
12 13 entraînements par semaine donc et
puis ensuite on relâchera
progressivement pour arriver en forme
aux Jeux olympiques et comment
appréhendez-vous cette cette compétition
vous allez vous mettre peut-être dans
dans votre bulle sur dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois ou
justement vous allez tenter de vous ouir
un petit peu vers l'extérieur d'écouter
des conseils par exemple alors sera
toujours à l'écoute des conseils même
s'il y a beaucoup d'expérience dans le
bateau Fran solforoszi a fait tr tris
Jeux Olympiques enfin ce seront ces
troisè Jeux Olympiques Guillaume renud
été à Pékin moi j'étais à Londres donc
il a que Tibo Collard qui aura pour qui
ce sera ses premiers Jeux Olympiques
sera débutant sur l'épreuve voilà donc
on sait déjà un peu à quoi s'attendre on
va je pense qu'on va en parler entre
nous parce que c'est un événement très
particulier avec beaucoup de pression on
rentrera dans notre bule je pense en
arrivant au Brésil pour
l'instant on en a pas besoin et au
contraire il faut pas com trop commencer
à à s'enfermer à faire faire monter la
pression c'est pas encore le moment à
Rio vous y allez pour pour gagner pour
avoir une médaille euh à Rio on y
va pour avoir une médaille sûre et pour
gagner assez clairement ouais c'est
c'est notre objectif on a le potentiel
dans le bateau on sait qu'il y a des
gros
concurrents qui auront bien travaillé
donc c'est dans vos cordes clair c'est
dans nos cordes mais on n pas il y a pas
il y a pas de marche d'erreur il faudra
être bon entre aujourd'hui et la finale
et même j'ai j'aurais tendance à dire
tout le travail qu'on a fait déjà depuis
le début de la saison au mois de
septembre si on a raté quelque chose ça
se verra peut-être à la fin merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau on continua
su avec attention vos performances après
l'aviron retour sur Terre coup de
projecteur sur le
futsall les finales de la coupe des
ivines de foot sales se sont déroulé ce
dimanche au complexe sportif Europe à
hencour les rencontres phares de cette
journée étent le match des seniors
masculins Villepreux carrière Grésillon
le match a été remporté par les antinois
romain rpinier a pour le
montage du rythme des contacts du
suspense les finales de la coupe des
Evelin de futsal se sont déroulé ce
dimanche au complexe sportif Europe à
encour dérivé du foot à 11 sport compte
aujourd'hui 16 clubs dans le département
la discipline se joue à 5 contre 5 sur
un terrain de 25 m long et 15 m de large
les temps morts sont rares les
dégagement du gardien se font à la main
les touches se font au pied et à chaque
fois le gardien ou à la touche ils ont 4
secondes pour jouer le ballon en le
posant sur la ligne au total plus d'une
centaine de joueurs s'est déplacés à î
en cours le match phare de la journée
opposé les seiors masculins de
Villepreux au joueurs de carrière
Grésillon dans cette rencontre capitale
les villeespreusiens n'ont pas fait de
détail en écrasant leurs adversaires à 7
à 3 quip en face avait un très bon
niveau après c'est vrai que nous je
pense on a plus donné sur le terrain on
a on a montré qu'on allait tout faire
pour gagner et soulever ce trophée c'est
deux trophées ils sont à nous maintenant
on a tous fait les efforts voilà je
pense que que tout le monde a a
participé à cette victoire et voilà ça
fait plaisir on va fêter ça tous
ensemble maintenant à la base on était
venu juste pour se faire plaisir final
on repart avec la première place c'est
impeccable après avoir soulevé ce
trophée le FC ville pr enentera de
sauver sa saison le club est
actuellement en bord de la relégation
dans le championnat de football à de
première division de district et
pourquoi pas viser dans les prochaines
années la prochaine étape c'est la
Champions League c'est la Champions
League traap termine son championnat par
une bonne note les traapistes se sont
imposé à domicile contre malakov lors de
la 22e et dernière journée du
championnat de National 3 score finale
77 à 70 au classement les 5tinois
terminent le championnat à la 6e place
avec un bilan de 12 victoires et 10
défaites pour nous parler de ce match du
du classement du club nous recevons sur
ce plateau le président Jacques Michelet
et ABG barakaou le capitaine de l'équipe
bonour bonjour bonsoir alors je disait
vous terminez le championnat sur une
bonne note AB
voilà pour finir le championnat en
beauté à la maison
euh c'était un match accroché quand même
mais voilà on a pu tout le monde a pu
jouer et on a fini en apothéose ce match
comme le match d'avant à la maison par
une victoire et ça fait du bien à tout
le monde vous aviez à cœur de remporter
cette dernière victoire devant votre
public voilà c'était surtout une petite
fête on va dire il y avait un peu des
anciens qui étaient là parce que
l'équipe de qui tourne bien qui vient de
N supporter et ils étaient présents tout
le monde a participé à la fête ça
c'était important donc on on voit au
début à la fin le travail qui a été
réalisé voilà vous avez terminé 6e vous
auriez signé pour terminer 6e au début
de la
saison au début là comme on avait déjà
discuté de ça auparavant nous on a
n'avait pas de d'objectif particulier
c'était vraiment la progression sur
le sur une dynamque collective voilà
d'essayer de progresser et ensuite on
aurait on attendait de voir pour se
fixer des objectifs on a toujours
avancer match après match alors c'est
certain que c'est un peu rageant parce
que je pense qu'on aurait pu si dès le
départ on était prêt dans la tête à
gagner on aurait pu effacer quelques
défaites on aurait pu terminer plus haut
mais c'est vrai que à la fin de la
saison c'est quand même satisfaisant de
avec un groupe jeune reconstitué de
terminer 6e président 6e c'est une place
satisfaisante ou vous êtes quand même un
petit peu déçu vous avez quelques
regrets sur cette saison non nous ne
sommes pas nous ne sommes pas déçus
comme vient de le dire ABG notre
objectif de C de de cette saison là
c'était de constituer un groupe
pérenisable or je crois que cela est
absolument atteint euh nous avons eu un
début de saison comme on s'y attendait
comme on l'avait d'ailleurs dit qui
forcément était était problématique
puisque'en fait les joueurs ne se
connaissaient pas et donc vous êtesarti
vraiment avec un groupe neuf ah
totalement oui il y avait trois joueurs
de l'ancienne équipe c'était vraiment
très très peu euh et en conséquence les
premiers matchs ont été perdus par mes
connaissances des joueurs les uns avec
les autres par mes connaissances
personnelles mais aussi par manque
d'homogéité collective et en fait on a
on a trouvé cette ce collectif plus
rapidement qu qui attendait mais il y a
eu ensuite quelques quelques problèmes
d'équipe à savoir des blessures des
absences parmi des joueurs majeurs qui
nous ont fait perdre quelques matchs
comme disait ABG c'était un peu rageant
parce que c'est vrai qu'on pouvait ouais
très raisonnablement pouvit terminer sur
le podium oh oui oui oui tout à fait
cependant notre objectif n'est pas
n'était pas de monter parce qu'il s'agit
là aussi de se restructurer pas
simplement sportivement mais alement
économiquement de façon à à assurer la
suite je crois
que les les grands objectifs du club ont
été remplis cette année les trois
premières défaites àg en début de saison
vous laisse des regrets estce qu' au
final vous ne perdez que 10 fois cette
saison vous perdez trois matchs dès les
trois premiers match voilà quand on y
pense c'est vrai que bon il y a il y a
on va dire il y a des
matchs plus particulièrement à domicile
quand on reçoit vir celulà il fait mal
c'est vrai que bon même si on était pas
prêt en s'appliquant en étant un peu
plus il manquait quelques ingrédients
pour gagner voilà on a des
regrets on n'est pas amè par rapport à
ça voilà comme le président a dit on
avait pas fixé d'objectifs particuliers
on cherchait pas à monter après oui en
tant que compétiteur voilà il y en a qui
font mal à Marle on était absent
première rencontre de la saison voilà
même si on on n'est pas prêt et des
choses des valeurs qui font que
normalement on est prêt
à on peut gagner même en étant pas prêt
collectivement mais voilà il y avait pas
le feu au lac on a jamais eu
de de de de de de troubl enfin de
pression particulière et on était serein
pour pour enchaîner bah on a gagné après
pas mal de matchs d'affilé quand on a
été prêt tous ensemble à gagner ABG vous
parliez de niveau de jeu vous avez le
sentiment que l'équipe a progressé cette
saison oui l'équipe pas progressé hein
je pense que le président pourra en
attester
euh on a sur la fin jeou on jouit tout
tout le monde jouait euh les jeunes qui
peut-être étaient un peu moins prês sur
la fin ont joué et euh tout le monde
tournait on pouvait se passer des uns
des autres car tout le monde répondait
présent et c'est là qu'on voit vraiment
la progression collective vous confirmez
président il y a une vraie équipe qui
est née cette année écoutez je vais vous
donner non pas une opinion mais en fait
l'avantdernier match contre hvreux 3e on
gagne de 32
points et en faisant tourner toute
l'équipe je dis bien tous les jeunes qui
n'étaient absolument pas opérationnels
même à à mi-saison ont joué et on se
permet de gagner de 32 points contre les
trèm voilà je pense que c'est une une
bonne réponse quant à l'évolution de ce
niveau de de l'équipe de trappe notre
objectif aujourd'hui parce que c'est
maintenant que ce
les objectifs c'est de péréniser tout ce
qui a été construit cette année de façon
à en bénéficier l'année prochaine on va
en parler la saison prochaine début dès
maintenant il y aura un recrutement cet
été ou vous repartez justement avec les
mêmes joueurs d'abord une chose c'est
que l'essentiel de de l'équipe est
effectivement stabilisé cette année il y
a vraiment un groupe qui a été
construit mais bien sûr on va on va
chercher à à compléter de façon à ce que
le groupe ne ne tourne pas sur 5 5 6 7
joueurs mais vraiment sur 10 12 voilà
c'est ça notre objectif donc il y a des
joueurs qui vont vous rejoindre bien sûr
et Mustapha Larbaoui Mustapha pardon
excusez-moi mapha Larbaoui
quialementappe le président club de
footb de trappe Mustapha il
lafidi sera-t-il l'entraîneur la saison
prochaine président ben écoutez c'est
c'est une question que qu'on nous pose à
chaque saison
hein le comité directeur ne ne ne s'est
pas prononcé sur ce sur cette question
de la même manière d'ailleurs que
l'ensemble des des nouveaux arrivants ne
ne sont pas arrêtés non plus donc on
peut dire que à la fin du mois début de
de mai on aura on aura cette équipe au
complet avec ces dirigeants et tout et
la saison prochaine c'est la montée
euh nous espérons nous espérons et pour
cela il faut bien sûr des résultats
sportifs et ça on est confiant c'est
vrai mais il faut aussi que nous ayons
on un équilibre financier qui nous
permette de tenir parce qu'il ne s'agit
pas simplement de monter sportivement il
faut malheureusement aujourd'hui
également tenir économiquement or vous
savez tout comme moi que les subventions
de des services publics ont
considérablement baissé il nous faut
donc trouver un nouvel équilibre avec
une un financement qui soit diversifié
de façon à assurer justement cet
équilibre économique et et que l'on
quitte la précarité dans laquelle nous
avons été merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau bonne continuation
pour la suite je sais que le recrutement
va être va être compliqué peut-être
cette année cette année c à
l'intersaison on passe maintenant à
notre sport découverte le kayak
polo si vous aimez les sports insolites
regardez bien la séance la séquence qui
va suive une compétition de kayak polo
un sport qui mélange le basket le
handball et le hockey tout cela sur
l'eau est organisé ce week weekend à
l'île de loisir de Saint-Quentin envine
William l pour les
images ce dimanche 17 avril une
compétition de kayc polo un sport
hybride entre le basket et le canoé
kayak qui est programmé au centre
nautique de l'île de loisirs de
saint-quanttin en Yveline le club de
trappe reçoit C équipes dans le cadre du
championnat de National 4 en fait on a
une poule à 10 équipes et aujourd'hui
même on a deux en fait la journée est
découpée en deux zones donc il y a une
journée à trappe qui qui est celle qui
est derrière nous qui joue donc il y a
ass signé tu harcour Saint-Grégoire ver
sur scè et trappe et dans une autre
poule il y a les cinq autres équipes qui
la journée se joue à saint-nazer le
niveau est assez relevé dans notre poule
on tombe dans la poule bretonne où il y
a un très bon niveau on peut le dire ce
sport qui compte 2000 adhérents en
France est avant tout discipline
tactique sur le bassin c'est deux
équipes 5 contre 5 et en attaque le but
c'est de créer bah comme un peu dans
tous les sports d'équipe de créer des
décalés des blocs sur les défenseurs
pour pouvoir lancer un attaquant la
tactique c'est exactement comme le hand
en fait il y a des défenses de zone et
il faut trouver la faille en fait dans
la défense ce dimanche traap a terminé
sa journée avec un bilan de trois
défaite et une victoire contre
Saint-Grégoire le club organisera une
nouvelle journée du championnat sur
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin divine
le 29 mai
prochain après cette journée l'équipe de
Trapp occupe la 8e place du championnat
de National 4 on termine ce magazine par
l'essentiel de l'actualité à
sportive
on commence cette rubrique par de la
boxe le verrier roi Ahmed elmousaoui
affrontera l'Ukrainien Victor poknov le
27 mai prochain Cirque d'Hiver de Paris
pour une demi-finale européenne
l'ivelinois partira favori de ce combat
elmousaou a 26 ans et affiche un bilan
de 23 victoires dont 5 par KO et une
seule défaite potnikov à lui 38 ans et
affiche un bilan de 34 victoires et tr
défaite le vainqueur fa un grand pas
vers un titre de champion du monde on
prend à présent la direction de vois
Bretonneux la judoka j bridge première
championne du monde de l'histoire de la
discipline dans la catégorie des moins
de 48 kg à New York en 1980 était dans
la ville cquantinoise la sportive qui a
également coaché l'équipe de judo de
Grande-Bretagne a présenté au Centre
sportif des pyramides ses astuces et ses
techniques pendant le stage une
quarantaine de J de cas été présents sur
les tatamis pour suivre sec cours on
écoute les
réactions notre objectif est toujours de
progresser dans la technique et quand
nous avons la possibilité d'avoir une
championne du monde qui a exercé depuis
30 ans sur ces sur l'éducatif ça nous
paraît très important de profiter de son
savoir ça me fait toujours plaisir que
les gens soient là qui sont heureux
d'être là et d'apprendre et de
travailler ensemble on va faire du
travail technique une partie ça va être
au sol hein en judo il y a différentes
parties donc au sol on va commencer euh
et ensuite on va travailler debout des
des tech des techniques debout et
quelques petits combats à la fin un mot
de course à pied à présent la ronde des
butineuses était organisée ce dimanche à
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline au programme 10 km autour de
l'étan en duo ou en solitaire au
classement général Antoine Rondo a
remporté la course en 35 minutes et 15
secondes devant François laaky qui a
réalisé le temps de 36 minutes et 7
secondes le premier duo Christel timon
et Christophe Rousset lui terminé la
course en 46 minutes et 15 secondes
l'événement a tiré plus de 350 coureurs
le but sensibiliser le public à la
protection de l'environnement on écoute
l'organisation Francis ponce il était au
micro de William H on essaie de
sensibiliser les coureurs au respect de
la de l'environnement ne pas jeter les
bouteilles n'importe de pas faire des
petites bêtises de ce style là de
protéger les insectes aussi il y a des
panneaux d'exposition sur le
développement durable des che des
sportif on essaie de faire de la
sensibilisation en baseball les
coupgardes de montiné bretonau ont
marqué le pas dans le championnat de 2e
division après deux victoires contre et
sinon match d'ouverture les zontins ont
remporté une victoire 9 à 6 contre
l'équipe fédérale de T Toulouse mais les
yinois ont également concédé une défaite
sur le terrain 15 à 6 au classement
montigé occupe la 3e place avec un bilan
de tris victoires pour une défaite
Toulouse occupe la première place du
championnat on termine par du football
Guy en cours termine en boulet de canon
le championnat excellence les
cinquantinois se sont imposés 3 à0
contre l'équipe 2 des Murau en match en
retard au classement gu en cour réalise
une bonne opération l'équipe reprend la
2uxè place du classement auch chaîné la
formation est toujours en course pour
terminer un meilleur 2e c'est la fin de
ce 78 sport merci d' l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passer une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tbfil